حرب تاشيره بين الصين وكوريا الجنوبيه
واليابان ردا على فرد طوكي وسيو القيود
على المسافرين القادم
اصدارات الاقامه القصيره لمواطني كوريا
الجنوبيه واليابان بعض المسافرين الصينيين
وجدوا انفسهم عالقين في سيول بسبب فحص
ايجابي حسب سلطات المحليه
كيف يمكن ان يكون فحص ايجابيا لم احصل على
اي اجابات
انهم لا يقدمون اي معلومات ولن يعطوك حتى
فرصه للتحقق من نتيجه الاختبار بل يقومون
فقط بتنفيذ الاجراءات لم اكن مستعده لذلك
تمييزيه ضد المسافرين القادمين من الصين
وهذا ما تنفيه السلطات الكوريه الجنوبيه
من الصين على ادله العلميه
في وقت سابق هددت بكين بالانتقام من الدول
التي ستفرض قيودا على المسافرين القادمين
من الصين وتعاد كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
من بين البلدان التي اشترطت على القادمين
من الصين فحصا سلبيا الى جانب الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا وايطاليا واسبانيا
وفرنسا والمغرب وقطر